it isn't easy to work for the scp
foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant immortal
lizard or turned into organic furniture
inside the world's scariest living room
but it's also
insanely complicated how do you make
sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects and
entities
rather than a single object location or
being scp-001 is a cluster of over 30
different proposals for potential
candidates
for the prestigious zero zero one spot
some believe there's a true zero zero
one hidden in this group
and the rest are decoys others think
that these are all just scps catalogued
prior to the introduction of the current
classification system
some even think that all of the
proposals have a valid claim to the
scp-001 throne
we're not here to make a final judgment
instead we're going to take you on a
lightning round crash course
through 31 of the scp-001 proposals if
you'd like a more in-depth take on any
of these scps
let us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste
after all we got a lot to cover let's go
number 31
the chief of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report
every time the papers are read it
details the appearance of a new scp
that will inevitably be discovered soon
after the question is whether the sheaf
of papers is warning us about these
entities
or creating them itself number 30 the
prototype
this account details the capture of an
incredibly strange cycloptic creature
that emits massive amounts of radiation
and can create micro singularities
the writing of this creature's file is
so basic unformatted and
unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that dr keter was
killed
inspiring the creation of the infamous
keter class in his honor
number 29 the gate guardian this huge
multi-winged sword-wielding biblical
energy being
may have been the impetus for the
founding of the scp foundation
this being remains largely static
guarding the intersection of the tigris
and euphrates rivers
its flaming sword which is believed to
be as hot as the sun can cleave any
aggressor out of existence at the atomic
level
when the founder of the scp foundation
first encountered the gate guardian they
heard one word echoing through their
mind
prepare and the rest is history number
28
the lock this onyx gemstone and the
incredibly complex lock attached to it
are still a mystery to this day all
attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27
the factory as the name suggests this
scp is literally a factory
founded by a pagan and a devil worshiper
while it's believed that the factory
could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and feared today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses
number 26 the spiral path this is a
normal appearing gravel pathway that
when traveled clockwise
appears completely normal however when
traveled counterclockwise the path goes
uphill forever in defiance of all laws
and physics
this simple anomaly opened a pandora's
box of rampant anomaly creation
leading to a number of the deadly scps
we know today
number 25 the legacy this scp is a
collection of seemingly random objects
including a diary from a person claiming
to be from another reality
attempting to halt a trans-dimensional
corruption that they themselves created
the diary claims to have a solution to
this corruption but the solution has not
yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this
scp is actually the various authors of
the scp wiki
who are somehow leaking top secret
information to the public
number 23 the foundation this scp first
discovered by the fbi is an anomalous
high school building that experiences
shifting internal geometry
and sometimes manifests hostile
humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability
they can dampen or even neutralize any
scp they come into contact with
though it's implied that the 36 may have
the power to save the world
every time one of them dies a
supernatural calamity occurs
often leaving hundreds of innocents dead
number 21
keter duty this refers to a containment
facility largely filled with keter class
scps whose presence around each other
creates a kind of mutually assured
cancellation
if one of these scps breaches
containment that's bad news
but if all of them do it'll produce a
bubble of reality distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it
for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20.
oroboros this is a proposal that's
formed of four subproposals remember
what we said about complicated
these subproposals include the children
nine anomalous kids who emit radiation
and have destructive potential went
together
the broken god aka mekone the god of
metal
intelligence and machines atonement a
researcher turned into a humanoid
singularity with the power to destroy
whole realities and the way it ends
which isn't technically an scp but the
tales of the chaos insurgency's quest to
eliminate all the members
of the foundation's o5 council number 19
a record this is an scp file slot that
is itself an scp
whatever is written into the slot
becomes true and one ambitious
researcher attempted to use this power
to make herself into a kind of
all-powerful god
number 18 past and future these scps are
a collection of powerful entities that
despise humanity and are apparently the
source of all
anomalous phenomena even making already
dangerous scps deadlier than before
much like the database those pesky scp
wiki writers might have something to do
with this
number 17. the consensus this scp refers
to a reality restructuring event caused
by an occult
war in a previous reality that's right
this scp already won
and we're living in its new reality the
only people who remember the world as it
once was are 13 people who now
form the 05 council and not all of them
are telling the truth about what they
know
number 16 when day breaks this proposal
details a potentially world-ending scp
phenomenon wherein the sun becomes
hostile and begins to melt all living
beings into a living wax-like substance
number 15 god's blind spot this is an
anomalous area referred to as facility t
in which nobody can die this anomaly
dates back to the biblical ages of moses
and is believed to have originated from
the literal blessing of the abrahamic
god
it's through a covenant with this god
that the foundation is able to make
limited use of this death-free area
number 14 normalcy ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the o5
council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality
if something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business
number 13 the world at large as the
title suggests this scp is our home
planet earth
and its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on earth in our reality by
another dimensions scp foundation
hoping to continue human life after some
terrible calamity in its own dimension
number 12 dead men this scp was an 84
year old man whose body when damaged and
mutilated
can affect the very processes of human
death at large
before his own death he was used as a
dangerous pawn in a civil war between o5
command
and the scp foundation ethics committee
yeah we were surprised to hear they had
an ethics committee too
number 11 the world's gone beautiful
this scp describes an anomalous event
that will take place just before the
apocalypse
in which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace
before their destruction 24 hours later
number 10
the scarlet king this is an extremely
powerful extremely malevolent extremely
extra dimensional being
its worshippers attempted to summon him
in the ritual that created scp-231
and it's believed that he will finally
enter our reality after the death of
scp-231-7
you better hope you're already dead by
then number
nine a simple toy maker aka dr
wondertainment this is a reality vendor
who appears to be a normal human male
but has the ability to create other
anomalous objects
a number of which are now catalogued as
number eight
story of your life this is another
anomalous document that has the ability
to warp reality
but only when the writing contained
within conforms to a narrative structure
number seven a good boy this is another
anomalous entity created accidentally
by the foundation itself a neural
network was fed information on other
anomalous entities
in order to help the foundation come up
with better containment and
neutralization procedures
problem was the computer got way way too
eager with the
neutralization part number 6 project
palisade
this is another anomaly created by the
foundation this time to combat a
potentially reality destroying entity
known as the worm
the foundation created a number of
alternate realities as shields
but it's possible that this just made
the worm stronger number 5
05-13 the final member of the o5 council
who ironically may not
even be anomalous however seeing as all
the other members of the o5 council are
anomalous 0513's lack of anomalous
properties is therefore
anomalous like we told you earlier it's
complicated
number four fishhook this is less an
actual scp and more about the difficult
process of ascertaining the true001
if such a thing is possible the very
concept of scp-001
is to some degree an anomalous idea
number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre scp
regarding the permanent threat of a zk
class reality failure
how is such a calamitous event prevented
by keeping a strange entity in a cave
eternally entertained
the current proposed solution is keeping
the entity entertained by allowing it to
read its own eternally recursive
foundation file entry
number two the solution another one of
the most powerful anomalous items in the
foundation's control
the solution is a machine designed with
the capability of fully collapsing
reality
into an event of end-of-world scp
containment breach
and then finally rebuilding reality to
suit a given narrative
however things took a cosmically
dangerous turn when the machine began to
act on its own
when the foundation tried to reboot the
machine it broke and recreated reality
within complete data
this is the world we exist in now with
no knowledge of what came before
and how it differed from the world we
experience today finally
number one the tenderlos trinity put
very simply the tenderlos trinity
represents
three timelines that converge and feed
back in on themselves
even trying to summarize this one is
near impossible as its strangeness and
complexity resists all reduction
you can hunt down the tendulos trinity
yourself and hope to unpack its secrets
but
don't say we didn't warn you so that's
scp-001
is it one of them all of them or even
none of them perhaps that's a question
best left up to the foundation or maybe
the simple answer is that
you're just not meant to know we're
talking about information so privileged
here that it's protected by a mimetic
kill agent that'll quite literally make
you drop dead if you view the files
without proper authorization
you do have proper authorization right
quick click on one of these other videos
instead before you're detected